all right joining us now author of the
brand new book Liars leakers and
liberals the case against the anti-trump
conspiracy judge Jeanine Pirro in the
house and also was he's the number one
host on the Fox Business Network good
friend Lou Dobbs is with us okay if I
say I actually said if I said that I
said I'm kidding I said bad idea it's
not gonna work out well for you and then
I go through everything that Hillary did
but they're more mad at what I was how
did first how did they not get it
well they don't get it because they are
so consumed with the Trump derangement
syndrome that it doesn't matter who is
right and who does wrong the issue for
them is if you say anything they're
gonna hate you for it whereas one of
them just said I wrote it down where did
the idea come from
no the idea came from Hillary Clinton it
was a joke about Hillary point she did
these things you better deliver emails
destroy the evidence
in case we come for you but we're not
really coming for you for those folks to
take you seriously it suggests only one
thing wait a minute that really sounds
bad for those who I'd want to be alright
that moment was sarcastic as hell
absolutely it's been a fact I heard you
live and it was it was a funny bit it
was terrific but for those folks to try
to pretend in front of their audiences
who come to them for some semblance of
perspective on the world and tit and
take them seriously
wow this let me explain what happens
here they're attaching I don't know the
names of a single person that you put in
front of us and I'll bet you that the
MSNBC's audience doesn't know the names
of those and the reason they're
mentioning the name Sean Hannity in any
context at all they're trying to fix
themselves to some part of you Allah be
saying status how did I become clickbait
idea to say the women who support Trump
are no
get inside how dare you trash the women
in this country is dead inside because
we don't agree with you we're not
criticizing watching you right now knows
that that's a false statement oh you're
very alive yes all right what our
historic week glue
we're heading into you bet there's no
risk to the president here he's managed
the expectation I'll walk out maybe it
needs five meetings is not gonna sign a
deal but maybe we can end the Korean War
the president has communicated this week
in his body language his words his
actions just how on top of his game he
is this is a president who has not only
had the most historic a list of
achievements of any president since
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and he in less
than a year and a half but he is also
grown immensely as a leader now this is
a man who's a natural-born leader he's
led business he is like now that he's
figured it out oh he's this is a man
who's found his voice he knows things
he's known who he is throughout and now
he knows the job and that means if
you're Ryan you're McConnell you're
Schumer you're Pelosi run for cover
because he's going to have his way it's
my work sad that Republicans this is
their best opportunity all they got to
say is this is a great agenda
look at the economy look at foreign
policy everything's getting better they
should be happy you want to want to be a
part of it Paul Ryan yep can't stand the
fact that he doesn't amount to shoelaces
on the president's so scared me a little
bit there sometimes I get caught up in
those sibilants because I'm so used to
going other places rather than oh I've
heard it low I've watched in person let
me ask you not only the North Korean
summit but now we got this IG report I
have a problem with the timing of the
release 18 months we're gonna release it
two days after the summit the leaks that
I hear insubordinate with James Comey
are they gonna say that they gotta tell
us the truth Hillary broke the law
Hillary committed felonies Hillary
obstructed justice and called me struck
and others put the fix in and roll her
exoneration months before they ever did
their investigation look here's the
truth the Inspector General has no
power it's almost as though you want to
say thanks for the report but where's
the beef you know he doesn't have the
power to indict should James Comey be
indicted the question based on what I've
heard is yes
remember McCain got the criminal
referral after the IG report I would
we're gonna do this with Sarah and Greg
next - I think so - I think you're right
- I think Comey struck McCabe all in
deep trouble will they turn against
someone what he had but why do you think
they're building a proffer with McCabe
now hire well that was the the latest
struck page tax said it's being directed
by the White House what an Obama knows
it and Obama and when did he know him
did he know agreed you want immunity
hit the guy on those for somebody that's
really get inside you're doing really
well you know hey I'm sorry you know I'm
kidding
all right look good to see you